je peux pas trop vous parlez là parce
que j'ai un énorme d'égaliser aulas a
fuit de partout oui j'adore ton bien
on vous attend pour la prise de sang ou
bien sûr j'arrive monsieur
caroline ça reste entre nous mais je
dois donner un rein à mon frère je vous
trouve très agréable il ya un vrai
feeling entre ou non j'ai rencontré la
palud qui paraît à la mousse de moi
tu peux pas continuer à mentir comme ça
parce que tu veux dire un jour jérôme tu
va raconter de mensonge de trop c'est
quoi ça
vous fait quoi là tu là pour le dégât
des eaux
de dire à tout le monde que virgin a
envie de coucher avec toi c'est faux qui
fait aucun effet annoncé renier tu
marques tu es beau
tu dis tu plutôt attiré par des mecs
pour garant profond mais la
[Musique]
tahdiah ton que j'étais un looser
résultat des courses une odeur
savas qui s'est passé je pense que la
journée va être très compliqué
tu as raconté combien de mythos c'est
dingue ça barton empêcher aux [ __ ]
meiffren frais
j'aime voir une baleine bah oui c'est la
saison mais quelle saison n'y a jamais
eu une belle analyse jamais toi parce
qu'ils viennent nous avouer qu elle
vertige vous partez à sa place à
prévisible
j'adore
j'ai fait une radio ce matin j'ai trois
ça n'existe pas j'ai regardé dans le
règne animal n'est pas [ __ ] de
poissons pas pétain d'oiseaux 80